les élections
approchent des maisons accrochées des
maisons avec made
on va lui jusqu'à la maison
pendant
huit ans c'est dans le par l'agencé la
vente
d'abord elle vit derrière remontable ton
cap
cette
échappée de plats vous dire la paix
dans la broye
de l'ikopa d'écran
donné par la toile on me dit que wade et
toi tu vas garder le truc accouchent à 3
30 ans
auquel
mobilisés partout
regardez la cité bon jeu dans son ancien
quartier
gare de ça plonge dedans longeant la cdc
en droit c'est ça c'est bien pour un
coût de sa vitesse à lui
reçoit plutôt fiable
voilà les ardeurs voilà les 100-103 a
pas besoin
certaines comme thales comme ça tissu
continu continu continu
non la tendance continue continue
enfin un simple avis pour devenir
ok est-ce qu'on peut tanguy tu peux te
faire légèrement amendé mais très très
douce et un petit vent d'où les attraits
du
favori il est très très bonne voiture
mais ces voix là c'est très
bien comme ça c'est tout voilà partis
trop vite
l'abroger pas parce que ok bon avec sa
valeur n'a pas
attention afin d'aider times a cédé
genre à la taille ou descendre et par
des détails des gens qui travaillent
deux
satellites et à leurs
besoins
voilà plus lent
elle est en son pouvoir pour avoir
osé mais c'est quand même temps alors
que les huit meilleurs
adrià fire and we go to the kore gang
il remonte aux cadres montrent
la route à deux voies
l'histoire fait refaire
aujourd'hui
et
bien
tout now
et nice
longtemps
ces cieux
c'est bien c'est bien voilà faire des
plans savez quoi
au pire la cité d'habitation
l'échappée a cité
des briques
en faillite
belargent
ok
aidez nous compliments 10 ans issus tant
que
ça